here's uh terry bradshaw from yesterday
he he said
several things and i'm glad we've
unspooled it into multiple clips he was
on with colin coward remember he made
the stir monday on wfam with moose and
maggie right and he went all in on aaron
rodgers and this just shows how weak he
is and they should call his bluff etc so
when you do something like that what
happens other shows call you up and they
want they want in on it they want to get
some of this buzz we want to get some of
this some of this controversy stirred up
with our show being the one whose name
is on the graphic when shows like pft
live talk about it the next day so
congratulations colin coward you booked
your colleague terry bradshaw here's the
first clip where terry has things to say
about some of the mechanics of one of
the greatest players in the history of
the nfl roll the clip please
while
aaron rodgers is phenomenal look he's an
incredible player but i could sit here
and tell you right now he has probably
uh the worst footwork i've ever seen for
starting quarterback
i mean he but
i was talking to uh
john zarnicki this morning
and i said he's an amazingly accurate he
protects the football he puts up monster
numbers
but his footwork is all over the place
and i don't know if that's because he
got hit a lot he's
out of position and doesn't trust his
lineman very seldom steps into a throw
pretty impressive actually
i think terry uh what the hell is terry
doing what the hell is he doing just
tell me what is he doing his charm his
charm comes in large part from the fact
that there's not necessarily a filter
between the brain and the mouth yours
kind of comes from that too but
he's contradicting himself because he's
thinking out loud and yes his footwork
may be bad it doesn't have to be
lesser talent
proper work perfect exactly right
exactly
it doesn't matter see now you can yes
the wrist if you can flick the wrist and
deliver the ball accurately the
mechanics don't matter the mechanics are
the means to the end if you can get to
the end without the means
knock yourself out that's right that's
what it is all the mechanics are so
perfect that he can
cheat on them to a degree and rely on
the other nine mechanics that are
perfect and maybe his feet aren't
perfect to still get the perfect result
it's like steph curry it's like steph
curry yeah he's a machine but then he
gets to the point where he can shoot it
quick or fade away or not jump all the
way or whatever that's what happens you
know like a good golfer okay yeah we all
want to hit it down the middle then you
become so good at hitting it down the
middle you start to go well wait this
hole kind of go bends this way let me
hit a draw or a fade because i'm getting
that damn good i don't need to have it
like hit it perfect like by the textbook
you know uh definition every time see to
me this is where
like comments like that
now
terry loses
like uh to me any credibility you know
that that like
went out to like that something's
personal there's something why why are
you going there why are you talking for
any reason he can't any reason he can't
to criticize him that's that's what i
need that's what it looks like
that's where it undermines it so now
you're wait wait you're worried about
his footwork but yet he's the most
accurate thrower in the history of
football so you're gonna get on that and
nobody's taking care of the football
better and not even close in the history
of the football and really realistically
and i don't like like fighting back on
terry bradshaw with this but i'm i'm
just keeping it real and listen i'm one
that rogers is wrong it's this is all
this is all an issue i'm not sitting
here trying to defend rogers but when it
comes to this i mean anybody who would
evaluate aaron rodgers would tell you
his feet are like one of the most
special things about his football game i
mean that's what makes him aaron rodgers
he can he can move and
jump around in the pocket
and
make throws with the feet not in perfect
position but really ultimately like here
we've shown two plays and everything
like that where he kind of moved around
and hopped around like his feet are
perfect i don't know what so that it's
just that's a wrong assessment and it
does make it seem personal that way when
he went down that that route there
and think about the two different ways a
quarterback can play
let's say you've got
perfect mechanics perfect ritual perfect
everything you you're crisp in your
three-step five-step drop you move your
shoulders the same way it's very
repetitive it's very robotic you know
what that becomes it becomes very
predictable yeah sure defensive back
knows when the ball's coming out right
you watch the film you see the pattern
you know when it's coming with a guy
like aaron rodgers or a guy like patrick
mahomes who can move around anywhere
throw from any body position any arm
angle you never know when it's coming
out so while some quarterbacks may need
to wind up the slingshot just the
perfect way to deliver an accurate pass
if you can do that without yes letting
the defense know i'm cranking up the
slingshot here it comes
you're better off you're better off to
be able to do it the way that rogers and
my homes can do it
no doubt about it exactly right i mean
you're you know think about it this way
all right yeah hey there's a guy going
10 yards acro you're looking to your
right there's a curl route to your right
oh it's not open
now there's a guy going across the
middle 10 yards down the field he's wide
open
okay wait let me get my feet over there
and hop and tell the whole world i'm
throwing it to him great completion we
got a 10 yard completion the guy got
tackled but the difference is rodgers
and mahomes go wait he's open screw my
feet he's wide open let me get it to
them right now and they just flick it
over there turn their upper body and do
that and now the guy catches it and
doesn't get tackled because the ball got
to him a little quicker and all of a
sudden now that 10 yard gain for every
other quarterback became a 25 or 30 yard
gain for quarterbacks like mahomes and
rogers and see that's where stats can't
really quantify their greatness and what
they do on the field that way because
their ability to do that and be so
consistent to your point mike it it's
hard to show it on a stat sheet but that
split second they got the ball of their
guy is a big difference in the game a
bunch of times during the game that you
just don't notice unless somebody points
it out to you
and that stuff's uncoachable see i think
that's the problem you don't need a
coach when you can do that excuse me you
don't you know you need to harness that
power bless you if you sneezed or bless
you if you didn't but uh you you you
don't you don't need coaching when it's
just magical and effortless and they
have that ability like rogers like
mahomes to just glance flick it deliver
it guys gone instead of changing the
base and you know what the thing you
showed me a few years ago about how you
want to focus the the shoulder and aim
in that direction yeah that all helps
deliver an accurate football
if you otherwise can't flick your wrist
and deliver an accurate football if
you're one of the few on the planet that
can flick your wrist or throw it this
way or be looking over there and throw
it over here or throw it behind your
back or do whatever and deliver it
accurately you're in position to become
one of the all-time greats yeah that's
why it's rare but that's why it should
be celebrated not criticized and i agree
with you terry bradshaw is coming off as
a guy who's looking for anything he can
to pile on rogers because he's upset
with the way rogers is handling his
business chris yeah i mean it seems that
way and listen i mean i don't love the
way rogers is handling his business
either i'm i'm with you but i'm not
going to go down like you know
a a road of like falsehoods are just
like bullcrap to crap on them here i
mean yes he was done wrong
uh do i think he's being passive
aggressive and doing some things here as
well no doubt about it so it's it's he's
not handling it the greatest in my
opinion either but let's not start
talking about
footwork and things like that to now
pile on about how a guy's handling his
business off the field that that to me
is not correct and not right and
especially not when you're talking about
really the guy that everybody imitates
in football how to throw the football i
mean that that's where you you lose me
when you start to do that like brady
literally has made comments like he
copies rogers we've heard josh allen
talk about it he is the guy everybody
watches for mechanics so when you say
things like that i just go uh
jeez okay blah blah blah blah blah blah
c-a-t cat-cat cat
all right here's some more blah blah
blah from terry bradshaw on
the way that aaron rodgers is handling
the business of his contract with the
packers
if you want to be like tom brady play
out your contract and then move on but
in this case you can't force aaron
rodgers coddled maybe too much he has no
right to want to get the gm fired what
right does he have no more right then i
have to call eric shanks and say tear my
contract up i had a really good year and
you go well you've got four years left
on it
yeah but i had a really good day
yeah this is where
people need to understand the difference
between a contract that terry bradshaw
or anyone else would have directly with
the employer when that's it that spells
out the full extent of the relationship
that's right it doesn't and what happens
in the nfl where you've got two
contracts you've got two and i say this
all the time someone says well he signed
a contract he did but the union signed a
contract with the league and the league
signed a contract with the union and
players have separate rights under the
broader labor contract now for example a
rookie
who's operating under
a contract that was signed after he was
drafted first three years of his career
there in the damn thing he can do by
holding out because the team by rule
can't give him a new contract can't give
him what he wants
rogers given where he is in his career
he can choose to withhold services to
exert leverage he's got a price to pay
50 000 a day in fines that can no longer
be waived thanks to the most recent cba
bonus forfeiture lost salary there are
things that could happen to him
financially if he exercises those rights
but he has the right to not show up he
has the right to hold out the mere fact
that the cba says it's a 50 000 per day
fine if you hold out means you can hold
out yeah as long as you're willing to
pay the fine that's right so that's
where that's where it
it it becomes a problem but here's the
other problem chris embedded within that
because there still is a contract to be
dealt with
rogers has always been the guy who signs
the ultra long-term deal and takes the
money right tom brady had an easier path
out of new england because his contract
did expire he was able to go sign with
another team in free agency because his
contract went away and the patriots
didn't apply the franchise tag they
basically said hey if you want to go
godspeed and thanks for the
contributions and uh you know we'll see
you down the road at some point and and
uh that that's the difference because
rogers doesn't have that luxury of being
able to say i'm out i'm gonna go sign
with the 49ers the broncos the raiders
whoever no and the patriots went all in
on winning super bowls for like 19 years
in a row tom brady has nothing to feel
like cheated about other than bill
belichick didn't tell him he loved him
enough which i understand i mean or you
know didn't respect him enough but he
he's not going to feel cheated that you
know the organization didn't do
everything they needed to do to win
games rogers is gonna feel cheated
because of that and everybody in
football feels that way so you know
green bay can spin it any way you want
they are all most of the nfl looks at it
like yeah they've never gone all in on
rogers so there's that aspect of course
again the draft pick last year with
jordan love and all of that
and then to add on top of it what you
said mike is even more like spit in his
face to a degree he's been
overly nice to the organization
with extremely team friendly deals his
last two contracts extremely he could
have held their feet their butts and
their heads over the fire and been like
i want way more
and i want to re-up and re-up and re-up
and he was nice and let the first
contract kind of play out and this one
to add the years and i'm sure that's
where he feels scorned on top of this
it's a double whammy where he's going
wait i i literally did a deal for you
guys to like feel good we can go all in
on the future and win the super bowl and
you haven't done that and you drafted my
replacement and screwed me over and i
think that probably adds a little you
know piss to his vinegar too there um
that's not a real phrase is it
well it's close enough but you know
you're making a great point because
he could have decided
hey you know what if you guys are
eventually going to play this
year-to-year game with me which they're
doing which he's trying to blow up
frankly i'll play the year-to-year game
with you like kirk cousins did in
washington like dak prescott did in
dallas you really want to be over a
barrel i'll put you over right i'll keep
showing up every year i'll bust my ass
every year if we're going to play this i
don't have security game we're gonna
play it on my terms he didn't do that he
gave them security he got security he
gave them security and now he thinks
they're using it against him and
who knows what was said or what anyone
was led to believe back when aaron
rodgers signed his latest contract but
this is a guy who has never wavered he's
never waffled he's never given the
packers any reason to think he may
retire prematurely or he wants to go
play for another team and prove that he
can get it done elsewhere he's always
been all about the packers he's always
been i want to stay here for the rest of
my career i want to retire here i want
to play into my 40s he's been the
anti-brett favre and i think that's one
of the reasons why he's upset now yeah
because they're treating him like a guy
right who's been wishy-washy yeah
they're treating him like a guy who's
been greedy who they can't wait to
replace him with someone else that they
draft in round one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports